>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THINK BACK, YOU MAY REMEMBER
JOE BIDEN'S INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD
THIS FALL, THAT BILL EMERGE FROM
CONGRESS IN NOVEMBER WITH A
PRICE TAG OF $1.2 TRILLION.
THAT SO MANY ZEROS IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE BRITT HOW MUCH IS IT?
IT'S MORE THAN THE ENTIRE GDP OF
THE NATION OF MEXICO ONE OF THE
WORLD'S BIGGEST PRODUCERS, SO
THAT'S A TON OF MONEY.
HE WOULD EXPECT BIG RESULTS.
YOU CERTAINLY WANT BETTER ROADS
THAN THEY GOT IN MEXICO.
ARE WE GETTING THOSE?
WERE TO BE GETTING EXACTLY FROM
THAT BILL?
WELL, TODAY COME AT THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT WHICH
IS NOW RUN BY MAYOR PETE
BUTTIGIEG OF SOUTH BEND FINALLY
TOLD US THE ANSWER.
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY, WE
LEARNED THIS COUNTRY WILL
UNDERGO A "PARADIGM SHIFT" IN
THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOLD ON A MINUTE.
YOU'VE PROBABLY NOTICED BY THIS
POINT, THE MOMENT PARADIGM START
SHIFT AND YOU CAN BE CERTAIN A
WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE ARE ABOUT TO
GET SHAFTED.
NOTHING PERSONAL, IT'S THE
NATURE OF PARADIGMS.
THEY DON'T JUST SHIFT, THEY TEND
TO TOPPLE OVER AND CRUSH
INNOCENT BYSTANDERS.
THIS PARADIGM OF COURSE IS NO
DIFFERENT.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW PARADIGM WE
READ ABOUT TODAY, INFRASTRUCTURE
IS NO LONGER ABOUT ROADS,
BRIDGES, AIRPORTS, TRAIN
STATIONS, AND THINGS HE MIGHT
ACTUALLY USE IN THE COURSE OF
YOUR LIFE.
WE COULD FIX THOSE THINGS, BUT
WHY BOTHER?
MAYOR PETE HAS BETTER IDEAS.
HERE IS MR. DOUGLAS EMHOFF, THE
PROFOUNDLY UNEMPLOYED HUSBAND OF
KAMALA HARRIS TO EXPLAIN.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION, WE ARE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT BUILDINGS, ROADS,
BRIDGES, ALL THOSE IMPORTANT
STUFF AS WELL.
BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN.
THE SAFETY OF OUR FAMILIES.
AND THAT IS, AS YOU KNOW, IS
SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN,
VICE PRESIDENT TERRACE,
SECRETARY BUTTIGIEG, THIS ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION,
THIS ADMINISTRATION DEEPLY
UNDERSTANDS.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
DEEPLY UNDERSTANDS.
THEY KIND OF GRIN AND GO LIKE
THAT, YOU KNOW YOU ARE ABOUT TO
GET SCREWED.
WE ARE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
THINGS YOU CARE ABOUT ANYMORE,
MR. AND MRS. AMERICA, THOSE
STUPID BUILDINGS AND ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
THINGS THAT YOU CAN TOUCH.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BIGGER
THINGS NOW, TALKING ABOUT FAST
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS.
PROBLEM SO BIG THAT UNEMPLOYED
DOG UNEMPLOYED DOUG EMHOFF CAN'T
EVEN DESCRIBE THEM MUCH LESS
SOLVE THEM.
THINGS LIKE "THE SOFTY OF OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES."
TURNS OUT BIG PROBLEMS ARE A LOT
SAFER TO TALK ABOUT IN SPEECHES
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THEM BECAUSE
THERE'S NO EXPECTATIONS.
ROADS, BRIDGES, BUILDINGS ARE
VERY DIFFERENT.
THINGS THAT ARE EXPENSIVE OR
HARD TO DO.
BUILDINGS ROADS AND BRIDGES ARE
FALLING APART.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CIVIL ENGINEERS THAT
KEEPS TRACKS OF THESE THINGS,
THERE'S MORE THAN 617,000
BRIDGES IN THIS COUNTRY READ AS
OF TONIGHT, MORE THAN 46,000 OF
THOSE BRIDGES ARE CONSIDERED
"STRUCTURALLY DEFICIENT."
THAT MEANS THEY ARE IN TERRIBLE
SHAPE.
KIND OF A BIG DEAL FOR A BRIDGE.
AS FAR ROADS, 43% OF ALL PUBLIC
ROADWAYS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE "IN
POOR OR MEDIOCRE CONDITION."
IN OTHER WORDS, WE ACTUALLY ARE
MEXICO, ALTHOUGH A LOT RICHER.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THIS?
WHAT IS THE $1.2 TRILLION PLAN
GOING TO DO FOR OUR CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
MORE SPEED CAMERAS.
ACCORDING TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, HE WOULD LIKE
TO "PROMOTE GREATER USE OF SPEED
CAMERAS" WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
SAYS COULD PROVIDE MORE
EQUITABLE ENFORCEMENT THAN
POLICE TRAFFIC STOPS.
GOT THAT?
SO BECAUSE OF EQUITY, YOU ARE
ABOUT TO GET A LOT MORE SPEEDING
TICKETS FROM ROBOTS.
SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
SHUT UP, RACIST, PAY THE FINE!
[LAUGHS]
THEY DO THEY NEED THE MONEY FROM
INFRASTRUCTURE.
"WHEN CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED
A BOND IN 2008 FOR A HIGH-SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM FROM L.A. TO
SAN FRANCISCO, THE PROJECT WAS
SUPPOSED TO COST 33 BILLION AND
BE COMPLETED BY 2020.
THAT JOB IS NOW PROJECTED TO
FINISH IN 2033 FOR 100 BILLION,
THOSE ESTIMATES ARE DATED AND
THERE IS AN $80 BILLION FUNDING
GAP.
SO INFRASTRUCTURE IS EXPENSIVE.
NOBODY REALLY KNOWS HOW MUCH
INFO STRUCTURE BECAUSE BECAUSE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEVER GETS
COMPLETED.
THERE ARE STILL WORKING TRAINS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE NOW
GETTING ROBBED LIKE THEY WERE IN
THE 1870s.
UNION PACIFIC IS NOW
CONTEMPLATING ABANDONING THE
STATE AFTER MORE THAN 150 YEARS
THERE.
KIND OF A BIG DEAL.
WHAT DOES MAYOR PETE THINK OF
THIS?
HE HASN'T SAID A SINGLE WORD
ABOUT IT.
OF COURSE, NOTHING TO DO WITH
EQUITY, SO IT'S BENEATH HIS
RADAR.
BY THE WAY, IT IS NOT JUST
TRAINS THAT ARE IN TROUBLE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WE ARE ALSO SHORT 80,000 TRUCK
DRIVERS.
THAT COULD BE PART OF THE REASON
THAT THE SHELVES AT YOUR LOCAL
GROCERY STORE ARE GETTING BARE.
IT'S NOT JUST TRUCKS EITHER.
BY NEXT YEAR, AIRLINES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE SHORT MORE THAN
10,000 PILOTS.
AND MORE THAN 10,000 FLOODS BID
THAT WAS THIS YEAR.
GOOD LUCK GETTING TO FLORIDA
NEXT YEAR.
THERE ARE OTHER CAUSES OF THE
CANCELLATION, NONE OF WHICH
MAYOR PETE IS DOING ANYTHING TO
FIX.
SO THE PRESIDENT OF EMIRATES,
PROBABLY THE BEST AIRLINE IN THE
WORLD, RECENTLY SLAMMED
MAYOR PETE AND THE DISASTROUS
ROLLOUT OF 5G TECHNOLOGY NEAR
AIRPORTS.
CLARK SAID IT WAS "ONE OF THE
MOST DELINQUENT, UTTERLY
IRRESPONSIBLE DECISIONS HE'S
EVER SEEN IN HIS LONG CAREER."
FOXES CASEY STEGALL COVERED THE
COLLAPSE OF THE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK IN THIS NATION.
HERE IS AN OVERVIEW.
>> MORE CHAOS FOR FOLKS TRYING
TO GET HOME AFTER THE HOLIDAYS.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE LAST
NIGHT.
SO THEY CANCELED AND NOW I'M
GETTING A FLIGHT WITH UNITED.
HOPEFULLY LEAVING THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> AIRLINES CANCELING THOUSANDS
OF FLIGHT ON TUESDAY AND
DELAYING THOUSANDS MORE.
WEAVING ANXIOUS PASSENGERS
STRANDED AND FRUSTRATED AT
AIRPORTS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE WIDESPREAD GROUNDINGS AND
DELAYS DUE TO ACCOMMODATION OUT
OF WINTER WEATHER AND COVID-19
STAFFING DISRUPTIONS ON FLIGHTS
AND ALSO AROUND AIRPORTS.
THE WINTER WEATHER NOT ONLY
AFFECTED AND TRAVEL, DRIVERS
ALSO FACING TRAFFIC SNAGS DUE TO
SNOW AND ICY ROADS.
100s STRANDED OVERNIGHT.
>> Tucker: THINGS WERE BAD IN
VIRGINIA, BUT IT'S NOT JUST
VIRGINIA.
OFFICIALS IN CONNECTICUT
RECENTLY REPORTED 285 CAR
CRASHES BECAUSE OF "ICY
WEATHER."
FORGOT TO SALT THE ROADS.
SAME IN NEW YORK STATE.
WESTCHESTER COUNTY.
PEOPLE FORGOT TO SALT THE ROADS.
THE FEDS DIDN'T SALT THE ROADS,
PEOPLE DIED.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
EQUITY?
SO HERE YOU HAVE ROADS YOU CAN'T
DRIVE ON, AIRPORTS THAT DON'T
WORK, PLANES DON'T TAKE OFF, AND
TRAINS THAT ARE GETTING ROBBED.
THESE ARE NOT SMALL THINGS.
WHEN YOU'RE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK FALLS APART AND A
CONTINENTAL COUNTRY, THINGS
GRIND TO A HALT.
EVERYTHING DEPENDS UPON MOVING
OBJECTS AND PEOPLE FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER.
BECAUSE IT'S A HUGE COUNTRY.
SO IF YOU HAVE PROBLEMS LIKE
THESE, WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL TO
OUR ECONOMY AND THE WAY WE LIVE
TO THE COUNTRY ITSELF, IT MIGHT
BE A GOOD IDEA TO HIRE A
CONFIDENT TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY.
THAT IS NOT WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID.
THEY HAVE A MORE PROGRESSIVE
IDEA.
JOE BIDEN HIRED A KID BY
CONTRAST WHO HAD NEVER HAD A
REAL JOB OUTSIDE OF McKINSEY
AND NO GROUNDING OF ANY KIND IN
PHYSICAL REALITY.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE HE WAS THE
MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND.
WHAT IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE?
WELL, WHEN PETE BUTTIGIEG WAS
THERE, THEY HAD THE WORST
POSSIBLE SITUATION IN THE STATE
ACCORDING TO THE LOCAL PAPER.
HUGE POTHOLES.
SO BIG AT THAT MAYOR PETE ON A
TALL MAN COULD HAVE DISAPPEARED
INTO ONE.
PICTURE HIS LITTLE LEGS UP IN
THE AIR.
EIGHT YEARS AS MAYOR, HE WAS
NEVER ABLE TO FIX IT.
>> IT'S JUST ENOUGH RESOURCES,
ONLY EVERY 100 YEARS OR SO.
I WOULD SAY IT'S THE CONSTANT
BATTLE WITH THAT NATURAL ENEMY
OF ALL MAYORS, THE POTHOLES.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
IT WAS A GUY WHO LITERALLY
COULDN'T FIX THE POTHOLES IN
SOUTH BEND, INDIANA, IS NOW THE
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE!
PRETTY AMUSING.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WOULDN'T KNOW
A CAR TRANSMISSION FROM A
BRIDGE.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES HE CAN RUN
HIS OWN ESPRESSO MACHINE?
THE MIND-SET IS THE PROBLEM
HERE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST MAYOR PETE,
HE'S EASY TO MOCK BECAUSE HE'S A
LUDICROUS FIGURE.
BUT IT'S ALL THE PEOPLE LIKE HIM
WHO BELIEVE THAT OUR ECONOMY AND
IS BASED ON SOCIAL MEDIA APPS
AND HR DEPARTMENTS.
PEOPLE LIKE THAT TO REALLY
BELIEVE THAT BY SOCIAL
ENGINEERING YOU CAN MAKE THE
TRAINS RUN ON TIME.
YOU CAN CREATE A ROBUST ECONOMY.
BECAUSE THEY ARE.
FOR EXAMPLE, LAST WEEK
MAYOR PETE EXPLAINED THAT THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY OF THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A MASSIVE SHORTAGE OF
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS, TRAINS
ARE GETTING ROBBED, PLANES CAN'T
TAKE OFF, IS EQUITY!
[LAUGHS]
'S ANNUITY YOU CAN DO?
WE NEED TO WORK EXTRA HARD TO
SCREEN OUT ANYBODY WHO MIGHT BE
WORKING IN OUR TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY WHO HAPPENS TO HAVE THE
WRONG SKIN COLOR.
WATCH BEARD >> YOU LOOK AT
SOMETHING LIKE THE INVESTMENT IN
TRANSIT.
AMERICANS OF COLOR, COMMUTERS OF
COLOR WHO ARE MOST LIKELY TO
DEPEND ON THAT.
YOU LOOK AT THE JOBS WE ARE
GOING TO CREATE AND YEAH, THEY
HAVE BEEN TRADITIONALLY WHITE
AND MALE.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO STAY THAT
WAY.
WE ARE WORKING WITH A LOT OF
FOCUS AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING FROM THE CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL BUSINESS
TO THE LABOR OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WORKERS, FIXING THE BRIDGES AND
STALLING THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATIONS, ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE WORKERS OF COLOR,
MORE LIKELY TO BE WOMEN.
>> Tucker: THAT IS KIND OF THE
PROBLEM.
THAT HAS BEEN THE PROBLEM WITH
OUR TRAINS, AND PLANES, AND
AUTOMOBILES FOR A CENTURY NOW.
GOT A LOT OF WHITE AIRLINE
PILOTS.
MAYOR PETE JUST SAID THAT, IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
THAT IS EQUITY.
SO THIS IS WHERE YOU ARE
$1.2 TRILLION IS GOING.
TO WHAT IS IN THE LEGAL CAMPAIGN
TO HIRE WORKERS ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR SKIN COLOR.
MAYOR PETE, YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED, IS THE WRONG SKIN
COLOR.
AND AS LONG AS YOU WANT TO ECHO
FIVE TRANSPORTATION, WHY IS HE
RUNNING THE DEPARTMENT?
BECAUSE HE'S TOO IMPORTANT TO
GIVE UP HIS JOB TO AN
UNQUALIFIED MIGRANT.
THAT IS BECAUSE MAYOR PETE WOULD
SEE THE BIG PICTURE.
HE UNDERSTANDS EVERY
TRANSPORTATION DECISION IS IN
FACT SOMETHING SO MUCH BIGGER.
>> LET ME TAKE 50 SECONDS TO
WALK THROUGH OUR TOP PRIORITIES
AND THEN LET'S JUST JUMP INTO
THE CONVERSATION.
OUR FOCUS IS ON SAFETY, OF
COURSE.
THAT IS WHERE DEPARTMENT EXISTS.
IT IS ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND THE WAYS THAT GOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE CREATES JOBS.
IT IS NOT EQUITY IN THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE CAN EITHER DO
HARM OR DO ENORMOUS GOOD IN
TERMS OF WHO GETS THE
OPPORTUNITY WE CREATE AND WHERE
THEY GO.
IT IS ABOUT CLIMATE.
RECOGNIZING THAT EVERY
TRANSPORTATION DECISION AIDS A
CLIMATE DECISION WHETHER WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OR NOT.
>> Tucker: I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING HE SAID
BECAUSE FOR SOME REASON HE HAD A
MASK ON HIS FACE.
MAYBE HE WAS ROBBING A TRAIN.
NOT CLEAR, WE'VE GOT A REPORTER
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT.
BUT WE THINK HE HEARD HIM SAY
THAT HIS JOB IS TO WORK ON
CLIMATE.
IT'S FUNNY, WHEN THE COUNTRY
APPLAUDED 1.2 TRILLION GOING TO
FIXING THE